après ce point sur l'actualité du jour
nous reprenons cette édition spéciale du
7 8 avec nos invités avec Johanna Soudry
également édition spéciale journée du
patrimoine sur téléfilm
en plateau
Marie-Laure estignard directrice du
musée de la ville de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines alors chaque
année un thème est donné aux Journées du
Patrimoine cette année lumière sur le
patrimoine caché sur 50 ans Yvelines par
exemple un parcours poétique et proposé
à travers à travers tout 50 ans divine
une balade qui va être ponctuée de
lecture devant les oeuvres de l'artiste
martapan dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure et à qui l'on doit notamment la
grande perspective alors comment ça va
se dérouler comment cette vie va
s'organiser alors cette visite
s'organise en fait on accueille les gens
au musée vers 9h15 le matin et on les
emmène en car non pas sur le territoire
de Saint-Quentin mais dans le PNR à la
maison de que martapan a partagé avec
André vauginski André vaujinski était a
été le collaborateur de Le Corbusier et
donc on va pouvoir découvrir l'intimité
de Martin c'est là-dessus que va être
axé la première visite où le président
de la Fondation martapan puis à la garde
va parler de martapan et une compagnie
Théâtre ppmv grain de sable
va donner des textes que Martin a pu
dire ou a pu écrire
toute la journée en fait après on va
aller à la Fondation Coubertin la
Fondation Coubertin en fait s'occupe de
fondre un certain nombre d'œuvres
ou de mouler un certain nombre dont les
oeuvres de Martin et on va avoir tout un
parcours toujours un parcours poétique
au sein du des jardins à la Fondation
coucouvertin on va découvrir aussi bien
des oeuvres de Martin que des oeuvres de
Picasso que des
qui sont et qui sont un poste dans dans
le jardin et enfin on va pique-niquer
là-bas puisqu'il faudra emmener son
pique-nique et on va revenir toujours en
car vers Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines où là
on va découvrir toujours avec la
compagnie de
grains de sable on va découvrir la
perspective de façon plus approfondie où
chacun pourra voir une œuvre dans un
contexte d'art urbain
décrite par les textes de Martin et
dites par une compagnie sur un ton
poétique et c'est une façon assez
originale je pense d'appréhender l'œuvre
d'une artiste un programme très très
riche sur Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
la fameuse chapelle des de la
commanderie des Templiers sur Élancourt
et oui qui a été restauré les longtemps
à la longtemps été fermé au public donc
elle a été entièrement restaurée elle
aura quoi ressemble-t-elle et bien
Maxime Le Maine Élodie moine et
Guillaume camps nous la présente en
avant-première
la chapelle de la ville du à Élancourt
s'offre une nouvelle jeunesse les
travaux de restauration entamés en
février 2011 sont achevés au mois de
juin dernier le chantier de plus d'un
million d'euros financé par la
communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin a permis entre autres de
consolider la charpente de travailler
sur la couverture et de restaurer les
fausses coupes de pierre à l'intérieur
du bâtiment
ce sont des décors qui restitue
finalement des faux joints
en pierre de taille vous pourrez les
observer notamment sur les voûtes sur ce
qu'on appelle les nervures les croisés
d'ogives les croisés d'osives sont en
pierre de taille elles ont leur joie
mais traditionnellement on vient
repeindre des joints et pas forcément à
l'endroit réel de du joint de
construction voilà donc la chapelle fut
construite au sein de la commanderie des
Templiers au XIIIe siècle l'édifice
religieux a changé plusieurs fois de
fonction au cours de l'histoire à la
Révolution les vitraux sont détruits les
fenêtres occultées la chapelle devient
alors une grange dans les années 60 elle
est rachetée par un promoteur immobilier
qui la revendra à l'EPA pour en faire un
établissement culturel elle sera rénovée
dans les années 70 par les architectes
Delaunay et bonne foi aujourd'hui la
chapelle accueille des manifestations
culturelles d'ailleurs samedi à
l'occasion des Journées du Patrimoine
vous pourrez découvrir le métier de
vitraiste
il a connu il a connu tellement d'État
il sent un scientifiques alors à
l'occasion de la réouverture de la
chapelle et bien l'artiste japonais
yukishi inoe qui résidant à la
Commanderie des Templiers présentera au
public une œuvre nouvelle et très
personnelle intitulée Les mille et une
tête ce sculpteur a travaillé la pierre
d'Okinawa une île au sud du Japon alors
pourquoi yukishinoé a fait venir ses
pierres spécialement du Japon nous
l'avons rencontré lors du montage de
l'exposition il nous a confié son
histoire
presque à la fin de la guerre il a été
mobilisé puis il a été il était envoyé
là-bas et puis c'est une il a tué quoi
en fait
donc il est en tant qu'un petit soldat
et puis moi longuement j'ai évité de
parler tout ça
ce n'est pas une histoire drôle à la fin
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale son père
est envoyé sur l'île d'Okinawa où il est
tué au combat un drame dont yukishini ne
parle pas jusqu'au jour où l'artiste
assiste au 60e anniversaire de la fin de
la guerre en 2005 il décide alors de se
réconcilier avec ses fantômes en créant
et finalement j'ai décidé d'aller là-bas
à Okinawa pour faire une sculpture à
titre personnel
et donc c'était
donc j'ai fait une sculpture je restais
pendant 2 mois et demi et là-bas j'ai
travaillé dans une carrière
de la de Pierre là-bas
sculpture de plusieurs tonnes il pense
alors s'être libéré de se souvenir
difficile de se passer marqué par la
disparition de son père mais il n'en est
rien la pierre d'Okinawa cette pierre
blanche et calcaire l'obsède
comment
et finalement du coup une idée qui est
un peu commencé bon dans ce cas là j'ai
fait transporter la pierre
l'artiste japonais installé en France
depuis les années 60 fait acheminer
plusieurs dizaines de tonnes de pierres
jusqu'à Élancourt et là yukishini trouve
l'inspiration
parce que j'ai pensé aussi et
une histoire de Japon une histoire
d'un temple de Japon
où on trouve
10001 comme ça
on disait que dans ces bouts de garde on
trouve le visage de bouddha entre
quelqu'un qui est parti qui est mort
quelque chose donne un souvenir il est
un bouddha comme mine et un visage c'est
ainsi que son nez des mille et une tête
qui seront exposées samedi lors de ses
journées du patrimoine à Élancourt mais
comme vous êtes une journaliste
d'investigation je suis sûr que vous les
avez compté combien est-ce qu'il y a
1000 et une sculptures
dit que voilà quand il compte il se perd
un petit peu dans les contes en tout cas
il y en aura une centaine en alternance
avec des blocs de pierres brutes donc
non sculptées non taillés du côté du
musée de la ville vous l'avez vu déjà
cette exposition vous avez l'occasion
non j'ai pas encore vu cette exposition
je la découvrirais comme tout le monde
ce week-end ce sera votre programme pour
les Journées du Patrimoine oui ce sera
un de mes programmes il y en a beaucoup
il y en a beaucoup sur Saint-Quentin on
peut citer on va on va en citer
quelques-uns juste un rappel il y a un
spectacle un dimanche toujours sur cette
exposition dont on voyait les images
dans mon écho avec donc des danseurs qui
vont travailler un petit peu les
expressions du visage en écho bien sûr à
l'exposition de l'artiste inway très
bien la suite du programme sur
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines alors un petit
mot Johanna alors on a beaucoup de
choses à voir à La Verrière par exemple
et bien la ville nous invite à un rallye
pédestre familial c'est dimanche à 15h
au départ de la maison de quartier du
Bois de l'étang Amani aussi ouverture de
l'église de Saint-Germain de Paris entre
10h et 18h samedi et dimanche et puis à
Montigny comme chaque année ouverture du
fort de Saint-Cyr pour les archives
photographiques de France avoisin
dernière date dimanche après-midi un
après-midi musical avec entre autres les
solistes de Versailles encore un peu
plus d'une demi-heure jusqu'à 19h si
vous nous suivez en direct le 7 A8 est
consacré aux journées du patrimoine sur
tvfilm mais quel sera justement votre
programme durant ce rendez-vous annuel
des 15 et 16 septembre vos réponses si
j'en ai l'occasion j'irai sur Paris ou
sur Versailles essayer de visiter un
monument quelque chose de particulier
voilà on a reçu le petit Quentin hier
donc il y avait des propositions donc on
va regarder mais on n'a pas encore
décidé
je crois que le comment le vélo de route
de Saint-Quentin Vienne porte ou je
crois que genre porte ouverte avec un
commentaire sur Le sur la construction
peut-être l'usine Renault aussi le
Technocentre ça pourrait être
intéressant et puis
Bouygues aussi